the Joe Rogan experience dope I'm very
lucky
yeah we are allowed we blessed for sure
if you listen to this you're blessed
you're alive today you're blesses mm I
didn't even yeah I like it come oh
that's um Joel Olsteen [ __ ]
that's me smile [ __ ] well that's a
great [ __ ] song yeah a lot to be
smiling for that song is the universe
all that was from the universe yeah yeah
that was all the universe I was put out
there for the universe I'd love to see
what it did that was the dopest [ __ ]
it's a great message it's a fun message
it's great to see what it did just the
people just have a branch people
together I just when people tell me what
they got them through what they doing or
just seeing older people seeing people
from from babies to 90 years old just
enjoying it so you won't even as a
comedian as I entertain to see people
just enjoying it and enjoying it for the
right way on what you put it out there
for ya you know you like damn this [ __ ]
working that's the best part of what we
do hey he's fine the best part is you
know work for me is like like you like I
really do what I do for other people
because I didn't got everything I wanted
you know it's like now it's just all my
agenda is for the betterment of other
people as a whole that's what I want to
see that's your ultimate your ultimate
goal
my ultimate goal yep my ultimate goal is
to have a little bit of look duval than
everybody I feel like if everybody act
like me the world you perfect it would
be more fun place for sure making some
good points I'm thinking about how can I
help Hong Kong nothing
I'm thinking about okay do then at this
point you can do something like if you
implement your the best thing we can do
in
let's just be the change you're gonna
see just be that everything we are is
what we saw so you have to give more
examples of that moving the movement
that you want one up is the move and it
trickles down over time the butterfly
fit everything is the butterfly fit
Dontrelle so you're trying to change
that's how you change it but in the
meantime that [ __ ] gonna happen I don't
know who writer who wrote depends on
which side you that right hmm that's the
second one mm-hmm don't know who's white
or who's wrong depends on what side
you're on
mmm Lil Duval bars you can see that like
you know like all black screen white
letters no face black and the beginning
of a film you hit the JLo moment no no
give me that lighter
[Applause]